Time-hopping cops with a budget that only lets
them travel to the '80s?? A cyborg satire watered
down for mass consumption?! The movies are
classics. The TV spin-offs flopped hard.
A surprise success, "Alien Nation" hit the
big screen in 1988 with a story set three
years after an alien race called the Newcomers
arrive on Earth and integrate into human society.
James Caan stars as Detective Matt Sykes, who's
partnered with Newcomer Detective Sam Francisco,
played by Mandy Patinkin, to hunt down a
killer on the loose. A mix of crime noir,
science fiction, and buddy cop tropes, the
film yielded a TV spin-off one year later.
This new version, as reimagined by series creator
Kenneth Johnson, is less a buddy cop action series
and more of a gritty cop drama that explores
real issues. In an interview with Games Radar,
Johnson said he wanted to use the science fiction
elements of the film to examine social and
political problems and racial politics. On top of
the police stories, the series put a focus on the
problems of bigotry faced by Francisco's alien
family as they integrate into Earth culture.
The series garnered mixed reviews upon
release, and ratings at the time weren't
strong enough to keep it afloat, leading to
cancellation after just 22 episodes. Thankfully,
perhaps due to the success of "The X-Files"
later that decade, Fox was able to resurrect
"Alien Nation" as a series of five television
movies, with its final entry landing in 1997.
"See, I haven't gone completely
human." "Yeah dad, it looks good!"
"Logan's Run" established itself as a
groundbreaking sci-fi adventure film when it
premiered in 1976. The film stars Michael York,
who more modern audiences might know as Basil
Exposition from the cast of the "Austin Powers"
movies. The story is set in a bizarre future world
where the government controls its resources by
executing citizens when they turn 30. Logan 5, aka
York, is a former government enforcer who begins
to challenge the system when he meets a young
woman named Jessica 6. Together the pair go on the
run through post-apocalyptic America in search of
Sanctuary, a legendary utopia where they believe
they can live out the rest of their natural lives.
Just a year after the film was released, a
television adaptation arrived with a new cast,
serving as a retelling and continuation of
the story. The show chronicles much more
of the characters' turbulent escape
to the mythical city of Sanctuary
and gives them a robot sidekick
named Rem. Along their travels,
Logan and Jessica encounter aliens, monsters,
and robots, as well as other runners, rebels,
and new cities. They have adventures in
dreams and even do a bit of time traveling.
An ambitious series that may have bitten
off a bit more than it could chew,
"Logan's Run" couldn't keep up with other
science fiction tales of the era. It lasted
less than a year and completed just
14 episodes before being canceled.
While HBO's "Westworld" reboot series is
the franchise's most popular entry today,
it's originally based on a 1973 science
fiction film of the same name written
by "Jurassic Park" author Michael
Crichton. The movie even received
a sequel in 1976 called "Futureworld," but
what's rarely talked about is the spin-off
television series broadcast later
that same year, "Beyond Westworld."
Where the films see malfunctions lead to disaster
in the titular android theme park, the series
took a new angle. "Beyond Westworld" features
a recurring villain, the sinister Simon Quaid,
who's stolen androids from the park for his own
nefarious purposes. Security chief John Moore,
played by Jim McMullan, sets out to
capture a new android replicant each week.
A promising premise, it may have
been a little ahead of its time,
and it never quite took off. The
fact that only five episodes were
ever produced may account for why
the series has faded into obscurity.
Based on the Philip K. Dick short
story "We Can Remember It for You
Wholesale," the big budget 1990 sci-fi film
"Total Recall" is an over-the-top action
adventure led by Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Schwarzenegger stars as Douglas Quaid,
a construction worker who opts to have
memory implants of an exotic secret agent
life as part of a virtual vacation package.
But the procedure goes wrong, and Quaid soon
discovers that he may be an undercover agent
for real, sending him on a mission to Mars.
"See you at the party, Richter."
A TV spin-off titled "Total Recall
2070" launched on Showtime in 1997.
Despite its title, "Total Recall 2070" acts more
like a spin-off of a different iconic sci-fi film,
the 1982 classic "Blade Runner." In the series,
we meet Michael Easton's Detective David Hume
of the Citizens Protection Bureau, who's
reluctantly paired with a synthetic partner in
the straight-laced replicant Ian Farve, played
by Karl Pruner. The mismatched cops are tasked
with investigating all manner of crimes in the
city, many of which involve the Consortium — a
group of powerful mega corporations that
includes virtual vacation agency Rekall.
Another ambitious series, "Total Recall
2070" works pretty well at times as a
cyberpunk detective series. But with
a high budget and low viewership,
the network dropped it after a single season.
"Consider that a divorce."
In 1968, Charlton Heston's "Planet
of the Apes" became a huge hit,
telling the upside-down story of an astronaut
who lands on a world where apes rule and
humans are slaves. With its shocking twist
ending, it became a cultural phenomenon,
and the studio rushed a sequel into
production. Between 1970 and 1973,
there were four more entries in the series.
But with box office results dwindling,
the franchise tried a different approach with
a prime-time network television spin-off.
Debuting in 1974, the "Planet of the Apes"
television series takes place some decade
after the events of the films, when another
team of 20th-century astronauts crash-land on
the world ruled by apes. It sees the return
of the film's star Roddy McDowall, but in a
new role — that of Galen, a young and curious
chimpanzee who begins to question the origin of
his people and is sentenced to death for heresy.
After Galen is rescued by two of the astronauts,
the trio escape the city and criss-cross the
landscape having weekly adventures fighting ape
oppressors. Despite the popularity of the films,
the TV version of "Planet of the Apes" couldn't
find much success, and it was canned after just
four months and 14 episodes. The network would
try again a year later with an animated
adaptation, which didn't fare much better.
"What a thick-brained lout that General Urko is."
Based on the short story by Philip K. Dick, the
2002 action blockbuster "Minority Report" from
director Steven Spielberg stars Tom Cruise, Colin
Farrell, and Samantha Morton. In the film's future
world, violent crime is eliminated through the
use of telepathic people called Precogs who can
see into the future. But when Precrime officer
John Anderton discovers he's been identified as
a future killer, he goes on the run and helps
upend the entire system, freeing the Precogs
from forced servitude. A television spin-off
arrived more than a decade later in 2015.
Set after the game-changing events of the
film, the series stars Stark Sands as Dash,
one of the Precogs who's been released, but
who remains haunted by visions of future
murders. With a new status quo, Dash teams
up with a Metropolitan Police Detective and
tries to help her prevent murders with
his unique abilities. At the same time,
dark forces seek to track Dash down
and use his powers for their own ends.
Where the film excels with a unique
futurist vision, exhilarating action,
and a captivating mystery, the spin-off
TV series is lackluster and pedestrian.
An ordinary sci-fi procedural, it failed
to live up to the film and got low ratings,
leading to Fox cutting the show short at just
10 episodes before closing its doors for good.
The 1994 Jean-Claude Van Damme’s movie "Timecop"
is a sci-fi adventure that follows Max Walker,
an agent of the Time Enforcement Commission,
which tracks time-traveling criminals. When
Walker goes back in time to stop a
killer, he uncovers evidence that a
powerful political figure has been using the
government's temporal technology to reshape
the future into his own dark design. Based
on a comic book of the same name, "Timecop"
was a surprise hit in 1994, and a few years
later a television spin-off came to fruition.
With a premise tailor-made for weekly adventures,
the small screen adaptation follows the exploits
of officer Jack Logan, played by Ted King,
who goes back in time each episode to stop
a criminal in the past. Unfortunately,
the series was dragged down by a lack of
ambition and a lower budget that limited
the scope to relatively modern settings.
"Well, thesenate thinks if we spent more time in
the present tracking down rogue sleds,
fewer criminals would get back.
We'd cut our budget by a third."
Beyond its inability to dream big, the
"Timecop" show was simply cheap looking,
poorly produced, and often just plain
boring. In the end, just nine episodes
were aired. The fact that nobody really
remembers this one is sadly no surprise.
In 1984, director John Carpenter helmed
a thoughtful and romantic science fiction
drama called "Starman." The film stars Jeff
Bridges as an alien entity who's stranded on
Earth and befriends a young woman named
Jenny, played by Karen Allen. The alien
is also wearing a body that resembles her
dead husband. While the two fall in love,
Starman searches for a way to return
to his home. Bridges received an Oscar
nomination for Best Actor, and a TV
spin-off arrived two years later.
Set more than a decade after the film, "Starman"
the series sees the alien being return to find the
child he fathered with Jenny. Taking the shape
of photojournalist Paul Forrester, played by
Robert Hays, he reconnects with his now-teenaged
son, and each week the alien and his human child
set out to find his missing mother. At the same
time, they must also outrun the government forces
who are hunting them, including a determined
investigator who believes them to be a danger.
Focusing on the father and son relationship,
"Starman" the series loses the romance of the
film, exchanging it for a kid-friendly
adventure. Ultimately, it wasn't enough,
lasting just one season and
being all but forgotten today.
"We're gone. We're history."
Paul Verhoeven's 1987 hit "RoboCop" is a
sci-fi classic with a dystopian view of
the future that feels eerily prescient today.
Packed with social allegory that touches on
corporate greed, class inequality, and
the militarization of law enforcement,
"RoboCop" is much more than a thrilling sci-fi
action adventure. The film stars Peter Weller
as Alex Murphy — a cop who's critically wounded
in the line of duty and turned into a cyborg as
part of a new police program. "RoboCop" was
one of the best action movies of the decade.
"Your move, creep."
A pair of big-screen sequels
followed in 1990 and 1993,
and a live-action TV spin-off landed a year later.
With a fairly sizable budget for its day, the
series looked pretty good at the time. While
the creators returned "RoboCop" to its
roots with plenty of social commentary,
being confined to television meant ditching the
ultra-violence of the films, which turned off
some fans. However, the addition of Murphy's
parents expanded the character's story,
and the return of the classic satirical
commercials was a highlight as well.
"Be a superhero. Be a super shopper!"
Disappointing ratings saw the network fail
to renew the series for a second season,
though producers tried another live-action reboot
a few years later in 2001 with the
TV miniseries "Prime Directives."
The sci-fi comedy "Weird Science" was
written and directed by John Hughes,
whose string of teen comedies made him
an '80s legend. The film starred Anthony
Michael Hall and Ian Michael Smith as Gary
and Wyatt, a pair of high school geeks who
use their computer to engineer the perfect
woman, played by model Kelly LeBrock. After
creating their dream girl — the much older
Lisa — the two nerdy teens get into a series
of comical misadventures and wacky hijinks.
Lisa uses her own magical powers to help them
deal with their problems in life and love.
Bill Paxton and Robert Downey Jr. also star.
"Now, I want you to promise that you'll keep
your big mouth shut about everything
that has happened here this weekend."
A decade after the movie, a TV series arrived,
retelling the events of the film and giving
viewers weekly adventures of Gary, Wyatt,
and Lisa. Playing up Lisa's magical powers,
the series made the character into more of a
genie who could grant wishes, rather than a
protective helper to the two boys. But thanks
to its status as a cable network original,
the series could venture into more risque
territory just like the film. Never a major hit,
the series received mixed reviews, but
this was no single-season flop. In fact,
the show ran for five seasons
between the USA Network and Syfy.
Despite its 88-episode run, however, "Weird
Science" isn't talked about much these days.